>> Laura: IS A CONFIRMATION
VOTE FOR A BRETT KAVANAUGH LOOKS
SAD THIS WEEKEND WE CAN FORGET
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE VERY START
OF THIS WHOLE THING.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, HOW DID
REPORTERS GET THEIR HANDS ON
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD'S ACCOUNT
IN THE FIRST PLACE?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS THAT
SHE MADE THE INITIAL CONTACT
THROUGH THE ANONYMOUS TIP LINE.
AND ONLY AFTER SHE HAD BUILT A
RAPPORT WITH THE REPORTER, SHE
DECIDED TO COME FORWARD AND GIVE
HER ON THE RECORD ACCOUNTS.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS MOMENT
DURING THE HEARING THAT REALLY
JUMPED OUT AT ME WHEN I FIRST
WATCHED IT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GETTING
ENOUGH ATTENTION.
FORD WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
DECISION TO COME FORWARD AND
SAID THIS.
>> ULTIMATELY BECAUSE REPORTERS
WERE SITTING OUTSIDE OF MY HOME,
A REPORTER APPEARED AND MY
GRADUATE CLASSROOM AND I MUST
OCCUR FOR A STUDENT.
SHE CAME UP TO ASKING A QUESTION
AND I THOUGHT THAT SHE WAS A
STUDENT AND IT TURNED OUT THAT
SHE WAS A REPORTER.
>> Laura:
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IN THE
STATEMENT REAFFIRMED THAT FORD
CAME TO THEM SOLELY THROUGH
THEIR TIP LINE AND THAT IT WAS
UNDER SOME OTHER OUTLETS I
CONFRONTED HER AT HER HOME AND
PLACE OF RESIDENCE.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US?
BACK TO DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
REMEMBER SENATOR FEINSTEIN WAS
CONFRONTED ABOUT POSSIBLE LEAKS
LAST WEEK AND HAD THIS KIND OF
INTERESTING EXCHANGE WITH
SENATOR JOHN.
>> CAN YOU TELL US THAT YOUR
STAFF DID NOT LEAK IT?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE MY STAFF
WOULD LEAK IT.
I HAVE NOT ASKED THAT QUESTION
DIRECTLY.
>> DO YOU KNOW THAT?
HAVE YOU ASKED THEM?
>> ADJUSTED.
PARDON ME?
JENNIFER REMIND ME COME I'VE
ASKED YOU BEFORE ABOUT IT
>> Laura: WELL, THE JENNIFER
SHE REFERENCED THERE IS A WOMAN
NAMED JENNIFER DUCK, HER
LONGTIME CHIEF OF STAFF WHO NOW
WORKS ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
IT SEEMS TO BE THE AUTHORITY ON
THE QUESTION OF LEAKS.
WE TAKE THE POST AS HER WORDS
THAT THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN THE
STORY CAME SOLELY THROUGH THE
TIP LINE BUT WE ARE LESS CLEAR
ON HOW THE OTHER REPORTERS FOUND
THEMSELVES IN POSSESSION OF HER
IDENTITY?
IT IS STRANGE.
WE REACHED OUT TO HER OFFICE FOR
CLARITY AND AS A 5 MINUTES AGO
THEY HAD NOT GOTTEN BACK TO US.
HERE TO REACT, HOWARD KURTZ, THE
HOST OF MEDIA BUZZ.
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION,
MATT IS FLAT.
HOW WOULD, LET'S START WITH YOU.
SO MANY POST IS BEING HONEST,
HOW DO WE THINK ALL THESE OTHER
REPORTERS FOUND OUT ABOUT FORD?
>> EXTREMELY STRONG
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
STAFF MEMBERS DON'T TELL THE
BOSS, I'M ABOUT TO LEAK THIS.
LOOKS WHERE THE LEAKS WENT?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ," IT'S ABO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ," IT'S ABT
A WOMAN.
AND THEN IT WAS A BUZZ FEED
REPORTER, A LIBERAL SITE THAT
WENT TO HER HOME.
AND FINALLY THE NEW YORKER GETS
THE ACTUAL LETTER AND PUBLISHES
IT.
CHRISTINE FORD SAID, PEOPLE KNOW
WHO I AM.
JOURNALIST KNOW WHO I AM.
I WILL TELL MY OWN STORY.
>> Laura: MATT, THE IDEA THAT
SOME PERSON LIKE CHRISTINE FORD,
I WILL JUST TYPE IT ON THE
ANONYMOUS TIP LINE.
SOMETHING ABOUT THE STORY JUST
DOESN'T ADD UP.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF GUARDING
THESE DOCUMENTS, ON COOPERATED
FROM THE COMMITTEE, TO AVOID
THIS HAPPENING AGAIN.
SHOULDN'T IT BE THE CASE THAT
THEY SELL A PHONE, EMAILS, THE
TAX, WHETHER DELETED OR NOT ARE
PRESERVED.
YOU CAN GET THEM BACK.
ALL OF THOSE ARE PRESERVED AND
WE FIND OUT ANY CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN HER OFFICE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
SPECIFICALLY, FRIENDSHIPS,
ROMANTIC RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
FEINSTEIN'S PEOPLE IN THE POST.
>> ADAM THOMAS AND ANITA HILL,
THERE WAS SOME SIMILAR THINGS.
WHEN YOU GO BACK INTO THIS FBI
REPORT, ONLY SENATORS CAN LOOK
AT IT.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE SOME
LEARNINGS OUT OF THIS.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
EITHER DR. FORD IS A TERRIBLE
VICTIM OR DR. FORD IN
COMBINATION WITH THESE DEMOCRATS
AND MAY BE THE DEMOCRAT WHO
STARTED THIS WHOLE THING ON THE
LAWYERS, THEY WERE TRYING TO
AGGRESSIVELY PUSH HER TO BE
PUBLIC.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY LEAKING ON
DR. FORD TO GET HER OUT THERE.
THEY WANTED THE MOTIONS OF THAT
HEARING.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WANTED.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WOULD DERAIL
AT ALL.
THEY GOT THE OPPOSITE.
>> Laura: HOW WE,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" RESPONDED
TO US TODAY BY SAYING "NOBODY
LEAK ANYTHING TO US.
SHE DECIDED SHE WAS WILLING TO
PUT HER NAME ON THE RECORD AFTER
REPORTERS FROM OTHER OUTLETS
APPEARED AT HER HOME AND
WORKPLACE AT WHICH TIME WE
DECIDED TO PUBLISH HER STORY."
AGAIN, DOES THAT RING TRUE?
>> IT IS TRUE THAT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DIDN'T GO
WITH IT WITHOUT HER INTERVIEWS,
THE THERAPIST NOTES AT ALL THAT.
THEY TRY TO DO A LEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE COVERED SO MANY OF THESE
STORIES.
IT BECOMES AN OPEN SECRET.
A SOURCE TELLS ONE REPORT, MAY
BE A SOURCE TELLS TWO REPORTERS.
NOBODY QUITE WANTS TO GO WITH I
IT.
EVENTUALLY IT GETS OUT THERE,
SOMEBODY GOES AND
AMBUSH THE PERSON OR HANG OUT OR
STALK THEM.
THAT IS HOW IT EVENTUALLY GETS
PRINTED.
I BELIEVE THAT CHRISTINE FORD
WAS POP MIKE PRESSURED
>> Laura: THIS WAS ALSO
REGARDING WHAT IS IT CALLED?
"DEVILS TRIANGLE" ."
THIS WAS DON LEMON LAST NIGHT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HOW DID HE SIGN IT?
>> HE SIGNS IT, FFF.
>> BOY, HE LIKES MAKING'S TO
MAKE FUN THAT STUTTERING GUY.
DO A GOOGLE SEARCH.
THAT IS NOT STUTTERING.
"DEVILS TRIANGLE" IS NOT A
DRINKING GAME.
IF HE KNOWS THAT, EVERYBODY ELSE
DOES EXCEPT FOR SOME SENATORS.
>> Laura: LEFT [LAUGHS]
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
JEFF FLAKE, IT IS OVER.
OH, YES, IT TURNS OUT IT WAS A
DRINKING GAME.
OTHER FRIENDS GET SWORN
STATEMENTS.
APPARENTLY YOU WERE A BUNCH OF
GEEKS AND NEVER PLAYED IT.
>> YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM SOME
CREDIT, HE SEEMS TO KNOW A LOT
ABOUT IT.
HE WHAT IS THIS FOR NEWS?
IT IS OKAY TO PICK OUT A
CATHOLIC, THAT IS ONE THING WE
LEARNED THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WHAT IS THIS PHILOSOPHY?
DRINKING GAMES, "DEVILS
TRIANGLE" ."
THAT COULD BE RACIST TOO.
>> Laura: A BLACK HOLE?
SPEAK UP WHEN TO BE CAREFUL ON